what is the central dramatic question
well the central dramatic question is
just another way to sort of phrase that
idea that your story is about one person
trying to achieve one thing right so
it's again it's another tool to kind of
help you wrap your brain around your own
story um so whatever your your
protagonist is pursuing their story goal
over the course of that story um if you
if you phrase that as a question
that is the central dramatic question
and then that's the question that you're
trying to answer over the course of the
story right so
you know for for silence of the lambs my
go-to example it's it's will clary's
catch the serial killer um that's that's
the question that we're waiting for the
answer to that the story is
hopefully going to answer by the end of
it otherwise we'll be unsatisfied
what happens when the central dramatic
question is answered
then your movie's basically over
so you know that
that gives us that framework for your
story so it's the thing that we're
tracking um and then once that question
is answered it feels to us like your
story is resolved right so there might
be a little bit of wrap up after that
there might be you know some
an emotional button to put on the story
or like a subplot or something that
needs to be tied up or you might need a
scene to show us sort of
what's the character going to do next
where is their life going from here but
pretty much when that question is
answered that's when the audience feels
like ah okay this this thing that i've
been watching is now coming to an end
right like this is the end of it
well if we look at a lot of let's say
tent pole movies there's probably going
to be a resolution unless there's a
sequel planned and then they want to
kind of keep you hanging but some movies
don't seem like they always answer they
there's a there's a vagueness to them
yeah i don't i don't think an you know a
movie has to answer every question that
it brings up but that central dramatic
question
we want some feeling of resolution right
so i do think that there are movies that
leave it ambiguous and that's the point
um
but i think that it has to be clear that
that is the point right so then we feel
like okay so this experience of
exploring or trying to get the answer to
this question maybe we couldn't answer
it and that's the point of it and so
that gives you that feeling of even if
the
question isn't resolved that story is
resolved because we've gotten to a point
where we're like ah okay so here's how
this ends we don't know how that story
is you know how that question is
answered
so always know your audience is probably
much smarter than you give them credit
for but then if you end it in too much
of a vague way
it may just be that the writer didn't
have a clear view of themselves yeah i
think in most cases um
even if you leave it open if it's sort
of you know you don't fully answer the
question or you leave it an ambiguous
ending and that's the point of your
story it has to feel deliberate to your
audience otherwise
they will feel like you didn't do your
job right like they'll they'll sort of
feel like you left them hanging
unintentionally
and i think you want you always want
your audience to feel like they're in
good hands you want them to feel like
you are
you know what you're doing and you're
telling them a very specific story in a
very specific way
and
the things that they're feeling
were orchestrated by you you know what i
mean and so even if you don't give them
that like nice tidy neat you know
wrapped up thing in the end
they need to know that that was your
choice and not accidental
what if the writer can't figure out what
the central dramatic question is
um well i i don't think that there's
necessarily like one you know right
answer that you're you have to figure
out exactly what that question is
otherwise your story doesn't work again
it's more of a tool to kind of help you
and give you a framework for your story
and understand
what your audience is um
tracking in the story right so it's kind
of a way to get everybody on the same
page
but i think just thinking about what is
my
protagonist trying to achieve by the end
of this
um answering that question of who wants
what in this story and then um
turning that into a question is kind of
the way you get your central dramatic
question so it's knowing what your
audience
sorry it's knowing what you want your
audience to track
that's the question that you're that
you're trying to pose by the end of act
one if that makes sense well can we have
examples of central dramatic questions
in different films sure so um i think
the central dramatic question in crazy
stupid love right would be um
actually i think in that movie it's
it's
something along the lines of like what
kind of guy
will cal decide to be right it's because
he's
kind of at a crossroads in his life
where he's been asked for a divorce he
doesn't know
i think that he even says like he
doesn't know who he is as a father and
as a husband and um that's part of
being misguided by the ryan gosling
character is cal's at a loss he's sort
of adrift and he doesn't know which
direction to go now that his life as he
knows it is sort of ending um and so i
think that if i'm remembering it right
the central dramatic question in that
movie is like
what kind of what kind of guy will cat
or what kind of man will cal choose to
be and so we see him kind of navigate
that question over the course of the
movie right like he sort of gets taken
one direction by ryan gosling and then
around the middle of the movie he
realizes oh this isn't
you know this isn't who i want to be or
this isn't doing any favors it's not
getting me the thing that i ultimately
want which is my wife
um
so again i'm not 100 sure that i'm
remembering that movie correctly but i
think that you could look at it that way
that that's the question where we're
sort of waiting for him to answer by the
end of it
sure and and can he still be a good guy
despite bad things happening to him yeah
show that at the core he's actually a
great person yeah and it's part of his
character arc too right of choosing like
ultimately the lesson i think that he
learns in that movie is the thing that
he says when he stands up in front of
his son's middle school graduation where
he's like when you find the one you
don't give up you keep fighting for them
right so that's the kind of guy that
he's decided he's going to be by the end
of the movie is
he's you know he's not going to be this
womanizer who goes out and
sleeps with every woman he can
he knows who he's in love with he knows
what he wants is to you know to have
that relationship and so he's just going
to keep trying so even if you don't know
the outcome you keep trying for the one
that you that you really love right so
that's kind of the lesson that he learns
at the end of it
and then for silence of the lambs yeah
so that one's a lot more straightforward
you have a nice clear
external goal in that one um so the
central dramatic question there is will
clarice catch the serial killer right
because that's
everything that's set up and give the
context that we're given in act one is
like you have clarice you have a serial
killer on the loose uh she's the only
one or she's she's one person who has
sort of a special in to get help to
catch that serial killer so that's the
goal that's formed by the end of act one
is like i'm going to try to catch that
serial killer so if we just turn that
into a question it's will she catch that
serial killer and that is what the
audience is watching and waiting for the
answer to
and then to go back to the forrest gump
example i know we're using it a lot but
that one it seems like
there that's
a little unclear to me yeah and and
again i haven't seen that movie in so
long that i'm not 100 sure on how
everything plays out in it but it does
feel to me like that is a much more
episodic story
um
i wonder if i rewatched it if and again
you know there are moments that i
remember out of it but i don't remember
the whole story i wonder if the jenny
relationship is actually kind of the
spine of that story
um
and so
it could be
again i'd be guessing but it could be
that the the central dramatic question
has something to do with whether he'll
have a relationship with her but again
i'm not 100 sure on that one why do you
put the central dramatic question in
between act one and act two
oh well you know if we look at sort of
the
the basic structure of a movie you know
we typically talk about it in three act
structure and that's really just um
how
the pursuit of the goal breaks down so
in act one because really the the story
of your movie is the story of this the
goal and the pursuit of this goal right
like that's what creates the through
line in your story so act one that goal
is created act two the goal is pursued
and then act three it's resolved or not
right so they get the goal or they don't
so that the central dramatic question is
basically
by the end of act one we have all of the
context that we need in order to
understand what the protagonist is
trying to do and what they're trying to
do is answering that question so that's
why the central dramatic question is
sort of solidified or asked
for the audience at the end of act one
and then
the meat of the movie is watching them
try to answer it across act 2 and act 3.